you know what's interesting though is
all of this that we're talking about
right now what's happening on
these platforms it we met in chaz
actually
oh yeah that's right beginning of the
summer and what happened
there and what happened with a lot of
these protest zones it was like
basically
this kind of like utopian dream at this
at the onset you know but then they're
like
okay well how do we control the
information that's coming out of here
how do we make sure that no bad people
come in
and so they get security teams and then
they get people who make sure that the
only good press is coming out of there
and so actually kaelin
i mean you were actually assaulted as a
byproduct of you filming something that
was unsavory in the chas
hold on were you trying to undermine the
revolution
the the leader of the rebels
it looked like some i you know i don't
know what it was was it a revolution i'm
not really sure
but they they ended up uh losing
territory
you know what i mean they lost it but
yeah i was there i was filming something
that there wasn't even anything
happening
but i was like preemptively filming and
who are you filming rasamon
rasimo is hanging from everybody is
hanging out he was like the quote
warlord
all this stuff's going on nothing's
really going on i was sitting there
and i get cased but you were filming
them yeah
on a public street i was but it's not
public because it's part of the chats
now yeah it was part of
thanks i think we got we got to stop
here how you are falsely framing what
actually happened
you had entered into sovereign territory
oh that's right
yes and newest country violated their
borders
brought bringing in hate speech and you
tried to
undermine their government that was a
national security threat
and so like any good you know
protectorate
they made sure that the the villains who
illegal i mean you were a little
immigrant basically
yeah how dare you so and they and they
had to stop you from spreading slander
and and yes and undermining the
revolution how dare you but they had
legit borders i mean they had
checkpoints that they were checking
everybody came in
and it came to the point where once they
realized who we were they were basically
radioing
the antifa security teams hey hey hey we
were getting followed out i want to say
i did get attacked i did get attacked
they sent a guy after me they were
defending they were defending themselves
they were from your hate speech
i you know we won't i don't care about
who it was i know who it was but
uh the crazier part was that afterward
uh the guy that assaulted me was shot
three times
oh he was shot three times i think it
was three times two days later i could
be wrong yeah a few days later i go
but i remember afterward i went back to
the hotel then i thought if that guy
keeps acting the way that he did he's
gonna resurface i'm gonna find out who
he is
twitter went to town on him found out
who he was matched up his t he posted a
tick tock from the hospital
after he got shot and was he like
dancing no i mean obviously
obviously he's all he was all you know i
don't
know
what's that it's that what's the one uh
where the guy he's letting the chinese
government know yeah
you know the meme where the dudes on the
long board drinking the yes
uh dreams was he playing that song well
he's got like
you know blonde he's drinking the apple
juice from the cup you know the little
little tinfoil cup you know oh yeah
everybody in hospitals
yeah no but what was funny was that
his friends or whoever they were
afterward they came
they attacked my social media and they
kept commenting that i conspired to have
him shot afterward it's like dude i
don't even know who you are
i literally could care less who you are
i'm i'm going to washington dc because i
have important things to do
it's also funny though because i don't
think people out there necessarily
realize like
how amateurish this security operation
was in the chats like
shelby and i went to interview one of
the guys at the checkpoint and number
one there was a lot of like internal
strife like not everybody
thought raz was that you know they were
like who appointed him leader
but this guy i'm not even kidding he had
a needlepoint belt
and from that belt was hanging a holster
and in that holster it was a 50 caliber
desert eagle no there wasn't as yes i
swear
i swear to god man i'll take you
out and as he was talking and gesturing
this thing was like swinging around and
i was like yo like can i just
the reason why this isn't on camera is
because they asked us to stop filming
okay i was like yo
um that's an interesting holster you had
there can you tell me about it he's like
oh this is a needle
point belt i thought it looked pretty
cool and uh yes it's just holding my gun
my desert eagle i was like what
happening
swinging around hey would it be crazy if
you had like what is it a smith wesson
500 is that what it's called
uh how big is that it's massive it's
like it's
yeah it's massive i thought you're like
youtube like a nice like long beard it's
like
the joker's gone you know the joker had
that revolver where he would like pull
out of his belt but it was really
long and then yeah it was like three
feet long the barrel
i don't know if that made sense but it
was a good look so i guess a long barrel
you know there were all kinds of weapons
in there though i mean
that's recoil i guess people had rifles
people had everything um because it's
open carry yeah that's what
i'm gonna say i mean um but the other
thing was so
katie davis court and
this guy named maximus walked into the
chas with the american flag
and you know i don't i don't i don't
know what their motives were with that
but
it caused obviously a large commotion
and they got chased out
all the way back to their car and one of
these guys
security guys in a jeep with no license
plate
drives up behind to their car and he's
taking down their license plates he got
a radio
and we it was george ventura drew
hernandez and mae ran up to his car
what are you doing who do you work for
what's going on why are you taking his
license plate and he
quickly pulls his mask up and he says
well i'm with the john brown gun club
and well why are you taking a group
right yeah yeah
and by the way we got f that was right
after that we
they left in their car and then shelby
jorge and i
who because we worked together we were
all staying in the same hotel
we started walking away and i noticed
that there was somebody following us so
i said okay
we gotta you know we're gonna double
back down this alley we're gonna and
we're about three quarters of a mile
away from
three quarters maybe a mile from the
the border of the chats where our hotel
was and there's another guy that we
recognized from in there
and we were like holy [ __ ] we took holy
shnikes we took a could you could you
could you imagine how an american would
feel you're sitting on the beach in
california when
this boat pulls up and a bunch of dudes
jump out with chinese flags
and they're running through your
neighborhood you'd be like get out get
out of here what is this
so you you these people come in you know
it's an adversarial nation through the
borders with note with
without you know showing their their
passports bringing the flag of a foreign
government
and of course the the citizens of chiaz
were were
were furious i'm half italian so you
know they my
ancestors probably arrived without
papers anyway so it was interesting
though when i got attacked i ran out
because the guy wouldn't let me go he
grabbed the back of my jacket and he was
striking me in the back of the head give
me your phone i'm gonna knock you out i
didn't give him my phone
but there was a female who said go to
the medical tent when i finally got free
she said go to the medical tent i
ignored her advice and i and i ran out
and i ran about a block
and they sent three people after me to
try to take me back
for interrogation they said you need to
come back to the medical texts
this sounds really great i'm really
looking forward to when these people
have government here's control and power
the question is though is that how is
that
the answer to this crazy technocracy
that's coming
what this this this uh make your own
country anarchists to make your own
make your and grow you know take over
take over a a city park and and start
growing crops
was not was not going to feed not
growing
you know what's really funny is it's
like you ever see those videos where the
uh uh there's there's a video of a
orangutang and it's got a hammer and a
nail and it's
lays the nail down and starts just like
lightly tapping it
like it understands a little bit
a little bit but not enough to actually
use the hammer in the nail
so when i was watching the chass people
with their larp farm it was like one of
the funniest things i've ever seen
because like they put cardboard down put
dirt on top and then put a potted plant
right on top of it
i'm like that's what it's like it's like
it's like the hammer in the nose like
that they've seen a video on discovery
channel or something
and they're like i saw someone do this
but they don't get it but white claws
tasted so good in the chess
the white clothes they really did well
you could drink it i mean there's no
sauce
to be fair i was i was thinking about
this like when we were trying to set up
audio for this show
like i'm actually pretty good with audio
stuff because i've been playing music
and working in you know various you know
venues and stuff and we got this mixer
and i plug everything in and i'm like
everything is plugged in and working the
way it's supposed to but for some reason
just doesn't work
so i had to call a sound guy to come in
and he was like and then he just moved a
little things around i'm like that's
crazy
that they're they're you know you you
have a general understanding you can see
it you kind of know you can't do it
and so you know it makes me realize the
importance of specialties and why these
utopian dreams are completely
meaningless where they're like
if we take over these six blocks and we
have you know a thousand people
all we need is this one park to feed
them and it's like
how much how many acres how many acres
of land do you need you know to feed a
thousand people it's like a lot
right thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you